hello everyone and a special welcome to
all you Wizards Hobbits and good folk of
Earth and when we see Earth on this show
I mean all of it upper Earth lower Earth
the one in the middle this is versus I'm
your host Mark Ellis and rest assured
even though I don't hail from the Shire
I'm not only not wearing shoes my
toenails are also ghastly this is the
program where we take art artists and
artistic license to make our favorite
movies shows and performers duel in
combat against one another not literally
of course that would require a lot of
cleanup especially when you have the two
beloved thespians that we're featuring
on today's episode Daniel Radcliffe and
Elijah Wood I promise what I'm about to
show you is going to make you very happy
they might claim to be adults now but
they still look so young and precocious
and I say they still could play those
characters it skyrocketed them to
Hollywood's A-list and nestled them deep
within our nerdy Hearts yes it's going
to be a fun one today but not just a
book based battle for who's very famous
franchise stands tall is us we're also
going to be taking the eye of Sauron to
deeply examine the career highlights for
both talents away from the Limelight
they can go Blockbuster Big or in the
infantile with equal Plum and it's up to
me and my Sorting Hat to decipher who's
taken the match in one corner we have
Daniel Radcliffe who can play a
prodigious boy wizard he's also good at
dancing the night away or playing a jet
ski that runs on uh natural gas in the
other Corner we have Elijah Wood who's
just as capable of tossing a ring into a
volcano as he is taking down alien
teachers or dangling off a cliff hoping
Mom chooses the good kid those Lord of
the Rings Eagles really could have
helped in that scenario as well here's
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score round three characters
round four iconic moments and then we'll
do a Wild Card round that could involve
whose flicks have the more potent spell
castings or the best tree houses or even
who's gonna grow facial hair first like
I know I know they're fully grown adults
but they're faces they're so fresh the
movie and TV rolls dry up they could
make a killing in the shaving cream
commercial industry I guess we all have
to make sacrifices fun fact well this is
the first time either Radcliffe or would
have appeared on the program as
themselves their franchises did tussle a
couple Seasons back the Harry Potter
film property took on the Lord of the
Rings and it was an all-time slug Fest
we had Gandalf going tet.tet with
Dumbledore Gimli matching witch with
Hagrid it was a good one and the winner
was
they gotta go watch the episode be like
the other hundreds of thousands of
people that checked it out but right now
you are amongst the first to see the
stars of those movies step onto Center
Stage hopefully with their clothes on Mr
Radcliffe I heard about that Equus show
there's a lot more than horses getting
it on in that play Let's now do the same
here we go round one box office let's
make one thing clear right off the bat
Daniel Radcliffe and Elijah Wood are
much more than just Harry and Frodo
their Splendid talents with a loaded
resume that shows off their range as
actors but this is a competition and
round one is about making money at the
movies so I imagine the boys would want
to lead with their best foot forward
Lord of the Rings in Harry Potter are
two of the most successful franchises in
the history of Cinema and I was just
told before air that those films are now
available in convenient book forms Ah
that's convenient remember which movie
property kicked off its run first it was
Mr Potter who debuted on the big screen
in November of 2001 Conjuring a
worldwide total of 965 million dollars
and it was all said and done the very
next month Lord of the Rings The
Fellowship of the Ring dominated
December with 891 million dollars in
global preciousness so after the first
inning your scorecard should read
Radcliffe leading by about 74 million
bucks but our studs we're just getting
warmed up eventually they both have
movies that cross the billion dollar
threshold Radcliffe finally got there
with his last Harry Potter effort on the
Silver Screen as the Deathly Hallows
Part 2 grossed 1.3 billion dollars
topping the total from part one which
raked in 951 million bucks Elijah Wood
counters with Return of the King the
finale of the first Lord of the Rings
trilogy and its 1.1 billion dollar haul
The Two Towers did 919 million dollars
worth of business and it's worth noting
that wood does show up in The Hobbit and
Unexpected Journey and that movie did a
billion bucks as well I mean Frodo just
kind of shows up to say hi but it's the
Middle Earth version of a celebrity
waving good night at the end of SNL and
you're like that person wasn't in a
sketch they're just hanging out why do
you ragging me so much what did I do so
it seems like Global audiences drifted
into Harry Potter theaters at a slightly
higher clip than Lord of the Rings but
it's a good scrap thus far adding to his
winnings from the Misty Mountains allows
you wood also scored big with movies
like Deep Impact at 349 million dollars
Sin City at 158 million dollars and Back
to the Future Part Two with 331 million
bucks okay he's in that movie also for
like a second but look at that little
face the kid hasn't aged a day since he
was gaming in that Diner way back in
2015. you don't really know anything
about me what is also forged a
productive voice over career including
the Happy Feet films everyone loves
penguins which is why those movies
combined for over 500 million dollars
them penguins are so filthy rich yet
somehow they stay faithful to one
partner Bravo you little tuxedo wearing
bastards you're being ridiculous for
Daniel Radcliffe it's no surprise that
the Harry Potter movies dwarf or Hobbit
the rest of his catalog in terms of
dollars and cents but magic was also a
plenty and Now You See Me 2 where his
villainous turn helped Notch 328 million
dollars the lost city found 183 million
dollars in gold bullion and the woman in
black scared up 128 million dollars and
I was part of the paying audience for
that it's a really cool horror flick
but for these Lads it's not just about
the Blockbusters they've made a bunch of
tiny films that have grown sea legs via
word of mouth after their theatrical run
ended
so you've probably heard of Swiss Army
Man starring Radcliffe as a corpse who
apparently had a uh nice meal of beans
right before he died or Kill Your
Darlings where he plays Alan Ginsburg
but those two flicks didn't even muster
a combined 8 million dollars at the
Cineplex and Elijah Wood showed us a ton
of range at a tender young age with
early 90s movies like Radio Flyer and
north but those team up and land south
of 12 million bones which means I expect
both career totals to be Sky High but
this round may be won by the wall of
averages and is there anything that
guarantees viewer retention more than
laws and math there probably is so I'll
do it quick all told Elijah Wood
featured films have grossed 6.3 billion
dollars at the box office making for a
per movie average of 191 million dollars
that's an insanely High bar to pole
vault over does Radcliffe have the right
stuff
let's see there's been one two three
there's been a lot of Harry Potter
adventures and when we add those up with
the rest of his diverse resume it equals
8.5 billion dollars he's got the higher
total how about per flick average and
he's pretty good there too 406 million
dollars per movie
what's great about both Bells is that
they still have long careers in front of
them so this could change in the future
or when we go back to the future but for
today round one goes to Gryffindor
Daniel Radcliffe takes the point and
goes up one to nothing this is what I
look like when I'm happy round two
Tomato Meter slash audience score
all right while it's true that many of
all clicked on this vid or cast a spell
on your smart TV to watch it that's
completely mental simply because of how
much you loved Danny and Elijah and
their magical franchises this round is
all about how you yes you and the
critics felt about these films after
their release what were the reviews like
there's only one way to find out let's
get a can opener and make some sauce
Elijah Wood has been busy of late and
what are the apparent byproducts of this
tear has been putting a Fresh coat of
paint on his career Tomato Meter Outlook
his last four projects averaged better
than 90 percent thanks to a voiceover in
the Panama papers is a hundred percent
and 2021's no man of gods 80 percent
unfortunately in his history he's also
had twin 18 outings thanks to the last
witch hunter and Hustlers please don't
think less of me in fact some of the
most famous films he starred in prior to
that shoeless little fella in the Shire
didn't score big with critics Radio
Flyer is at just 35 although its
audience score is safely fresh at 72
percent and The Good Son improves on his
25 percent lashing on the Tomato Meter
with a 54 from the audience then we
arrive at the trilogy people have
compared it with Star Wars and Indiana
Jones it's possibly the best original
Three ever made and even though Lord of
the Rings doesn't have Ewoks yet that
might be the only species it's not
represented all three are solid in the
90s with the two towers emerging as the
critical favorite at 95 percent followed
by Return of the King at 93 percent and
91 for the fellowship you stay odd Frodo
Baggins there is no other way I also
point out that the Eternal Sunshine of
the Spotless Mind is 92 percent and
Paris juta aim is 86 percent and when we
factor in Woods's TV work he really
starts to kick it into high gear Wilfred
remember the the talking dog in the
costume that's 83 and Star Wars
resistance is at 92 percent that's so
much gold it would make Bilbo to his
momentary I must have the ring freak out
it's hilarious at parties and now for
young Mr Radcliffe we should all brace
ourselves for that new Weird Al movie to
be a perfect 100 in line with everything
else Weird Al's ever done and we start
with this TV work all right well it's
pretty solid miracle workers is it 76
and A Young Doctor's Notebook is at 83
percent and that's probably not a
notebook that you want to self-diagnose
with if you've got something to say
don't be shy all right let's get to the
real reason you know and love Daniel
movies like Victor Frankenstein and well
the women in black yeah that's a fun one
okay so one of those forays was fresh
and luckily it was the lady who wanted
to paint it black 66 which is still too
low for me unfortunately for the
Frankenstein family not every Offspring
is a good egg and this one hit the skids
at 26 percent of the Tomato Meter with a
35 audience score but Swiss army man
it's fresh all around it was a big swing
to take but both critics and audiences
said it cut the cheese I mean mustard at
72 percent on each measuring stick Kill
Your Darlings is also fresh all around
with a 60 from the audience and a 76
from the critics all right now I can
feel you hollering about the boy wizard
who lives under the staircase not unlike
the last single room Airbnb I used in
New York City I have a lot of questions
about all the things you just said Harry
Potter is fresh from top to bottom the
Sorcerer's Stone kicked us off with an
81 on the Tomato Meter complimented by
an 82 on the audience score and from
there we would eventually hit the high
Mark of the franchise of 96 with the
Deathly Hallows part two although part
one actually set the low bar with
critics coming in it is still fresh 77
the only other Potter tale to hit the
90s was the Prisoner of Azkaban at 90
even so we got us a real fracas here and
it appears to be close enough that I'm
gonna have to incorporate the small
screen exploits of both to arrive at an
overall average for each dude Daniel
Radcliffe gets on the board early thanks
to the audience score his per film
average there is 63 percent winning him
in fresh territory while wood is just
south at 56 however Elijah's TV shows
fare better with an average score of 82
percent to Radcliffe 78 percent to the
Tomato Meter we go and we're throwing it
on the Vitamix now 67 for Radcliffe 56
for wood although wood once again wins
the TV phase averaging 86 percent to 80
percent for Daniel so Radcliffe has the
statistical Advantage here but I'm
leaning towards wood in this round why
you're broken and empty and dirty and
smelly and useless and old you're like
trash right shut up I'm glad you asked a
couple reasons he got his start well
before Lord of the Rings and being a kid
in dozens of movies doesn't always mean
you get your pick of the lyrics
Radcliffe though he was already a force
in the theater only had one film release
before slash during he was Harry Potter
to generations of fans and once we got
into their signature property Elijah
starring as Frodo has a significantly
higher average than Daniel as Harry it's
a close call that may be going the wrong
way for a fair amount of you but I am
judge jury and Judy on this show and I
say Mr Baggins gets the point in round
two and ties things up one to one you
were right foul get you know that round
three character
okay okay Potter fans are you done
yelling at me yet you're being stupid
Harry Potter and Frodo Baggins are two
of the most popular characters in all of
Cinema or literature for that matter and
that's a good thing why well this round
is all about who has the better resume
of characters in this round to be fair
both potsy and baggy had a ton of help
Harry learned the ways of the force no
they call it at fabled Hogwarts and he
quickly ingratiated himself with
classmates Hermione and Ron who I hear
really enjoy each other's company now
but hey at least Harry Potter has two
friends Frodo Baggins spends most of his
journeys with one Samwise played by Sean
Aston but you always have Gollum working
and they don't really want sitting at
the lunch table with them
but he also gets some help from Gandalf
the Great and has folks like Aragorn
slaying evil and Legolas knocking down
baddies at an incredible clip with his
bow and arrow Elijah Wood has ranged to
burn as he's able to go from the good
kid and the good son to a soccer hole
again in Green Street Hooligans early
rolls showed promise as he was super
young in paradise and almost as young in
Radio Flyer and he was Forever Young in
a movie called Forever Young where he
played Nat a boy who Encino man's Mel
Gibson back to life after Mel was tossed
into a type of military experiment
stasis for 53 years the fact that wood
could hold his own with stars like Mel
Gibson Melanie Griffith and he was in
the war with Kevin Costner that proves
he wasn't just another cute kid he had
some serious chops but we're also able
to pay tribute to Daniel Radcliffe for
being wise and affable Beyond his years
if Elijah Wood wasn't good in Radio
Flyer we all would have gotten over it
but if Daniel Radcliffe at the tender
age of 11 couldn't make a believable
Harry Potter eh that ain't good luckily
he was and he's magnificent in those
films but due to their hectic schedule
he'd have to wait until after they
wrapped to really sink his teeth into
roles that were very opposite of a
lovable Magic Kid he played Igor in
Victor Von frankensteiner Victor Von
frankensteiner Igor whatever that movie
was he was in it it was right on the
heels it definitely how it was part two
but then he also got to do the woman in
black where he started as Arthur Kips an
unwitting young man who has to do some
ghostbusting Radcliffe also soars with
some biological jet propulsion
technology in Swiss army man a movie
that feels so whacked out for like 20
minutes but if you hang in there it's a
really fun Bittersweet rewarding
experience it's also fun to see
Radcliffe play the bad guy where he
plays shocker a magic Enthusiast named
Walter Mabry and now you see me too and
from all early accounts the dude becomes
ow and weird the Al Yankovic story but
Elijah Wood can expand his Horizons as
well playing The Eccentric Tony in I
don't feel at home in this world anymore
and a serial killer and Maniac who cuts
the skin off his victims heads and puts
them on the mannequins in his late
mother's shop it's such a toss-up in
this round between two artists who
almost seem like they're trying to keep
Pace with one another they have similar
looks and they can play the center of a
gargantuan franchise or Branch out with
fun eclectic smaller movies but early on
in his career Elijah Wood had the
benefit of showing off his talents with
a much wider swath of films than
Radcliffe and he was a standout among
the more established adult players sure
once Harry got to Hogwarts he was
running up and down the Halls alongside
Richard Harris and Alan Rickman which is
kind of what makes this call so tough
both have succeeded in avoiding the
ultimate Hollywood trap just being known
as one thing their entire careers so job
well done but I still feel like I've
seen a little more from Elijah Wood
before during and after Lord of the
Rings than with Radcliffe and Harry
Potter in what is probably going to be
another controversial call I'm going
with the maniac in this round and Elijah
goes up 2-1 over Daniel guaranteed to
Jack you round four iconic moments fret
not Harry Potter Enthusiast and kill
your darling supporters now we come upon
around chock full of the best scenes
sequences and scenarios within one's
film Vault and when you consider how
much content Our Stars have given me to
join in this phase you would assume that
they should look much older by now but
no are they like even aging I thought
the beard would help maybe casting
spells helps it's fun to do when you're
playing a collectible card game like man
Magic the Gathering but for Harry Potter
this is literal life or death and not
just for him even before it was clear
how imposing Voldemort I the guy that am
I allowed to he must be very brave to
mention his name there's certain moments
that gave us chills as we are all
finally witnessing them happen not on
the pages of a book but on a giant
screen platform 9.75 or as many of you
call it nine and three quarters nine and
three-fourths but for me the first real
memorable scene in Harry Potter war is
when we enter the Great Hall of Hogwarts
it did make me want to go back to school
but to this day we're all curious as to
which house we would have been sorted
into the Chamber of Secrets brought us
just that and Dobby gets free or as I
call him Gollum if G slice had gone into
therapy and made something of himself
but the real selling point of many
Potter flicks is the duels that keep us
in suspense which could be an intense
quidditch match or the first battle
between Harry and Draco many fans point
to prisoner of azkopan as the film that
marked the beginning of puberty for the
famed Trio of Harry Hermione and Ron and
it's not a coincidence that that's when
the S started hitting the fan we get the
dementor on the train the shrieking
Shack and just the overall mood of the
flick is darker director Alfonso Quran
even made a conscious effort to put gray
looming skies in the distance a stroke
of Genius on his part and a hint as to
what was to come while Mr Potter was
growing up and getting immersed deeper
into the Mythos of his world Frodo
Baggins is on quite a journey of his own
as in taking the ring to Mordor to
destroy once and for all luckily he had
help on the way from Eagles who picked
him up and let him recline In First
Class on his way they didn't take him
did they unbelievable they're less
reliable than Spirit Airlines seeing the
Shire live and breathe was a treat for
Tolkien fans and newbies alike On a par
with getting to chill at Hogwarts in The
Fellowship of the Ring were also traded
to cave troll battles in the mines a few
harrowing Chase scenes from which we
barely escape and here we just run it
one more time Bilbo freaking the F out
that might be my favorite scene in movie
history I have no idea what's wrong with
me then we get so many intense moments
in the two towers in Return of the King
and let's not forget how clutch Sam is
the dude swims out to join Frodo in the
first film and almost meets his end
there then he carries his pal up Mount
Doom which does not have Sherpas saving
Frodo multiple times on the way Sam wise
gamji always with the big shot he's the
Robert Ory of Middle Earth I thought I
wouldn't have got far without Sam of
course both actors are much more than
just these characters wood also has the
emotional proposal seen in Deep Impact
or as it was known around the world not
Armageddon we also have the
electrocution scene from the ice storm
and Eternal Sunshine earns a shout just
for Elijah's Wicked sideburns Daniel
also had the most bang for his buck
playing a corpse in Swiss army man
Bernie walked so Manny could run
Radcliffe has some legit scares to
overcome with the woman in black and oh
we've only highlighted three Potter
flicks thus far and it's already a close
call okay so let's get deeper Harry and
Baltimore have their first tussle and
Goblet of Fire and that's happening in
the shadow of the Triwizard Tournament
order the Phoenix would bring Luna
Lovegood into the mix and see Harry go
from student to teacher with
Dumbledore's Army then we arrive at the
Deathly Hallows unfortunately for Dobby
that title is quite literal and even
though I maintained the Baltimore kind
of mounted in in the final fight or
maybe he just didn't think he had a
chance of losing like when Tyson fought
Buster Douglas that's not Harry's fault
he beat the team in front of him on that
crucial day he was just a better man and
watching Hagrid carry Harry to Hogwarts
and sing the three of them all grown up
on the bridge see now I'm getting
misty-eyed it's good stuff those
children clearly took their Flintstones
Vitamins of course I did both Daniel
Radcliffe and Elijah Wood are allegedly
adults now with impressive resumes
featuring enough memorable moments to
rival anyone but at the end of this day
there's just too many great Potter
sequences Daniel Radcliffe in the middle
of it all and now he can play a great
Weird Al and the accordion okay he gets
the point in round four and we're all
tied up two to two well you know it's a
classic for a reason
and now it's time for the Wild Card
round I Need a Hero tied ball game as we
enter the ninth inning which is baseball
speak for the last round in versus but
much like America's sporting past time
when it is the bottom of the ninth you
want your best player with the bat in
their hands and thus the council here at
verses which is me we're on a plane with
no pilot
has decided that the final determining
round in this match could only be who's
the better hero of their signature story
Frodo Baggins for Elijah Wood or is it
Daniel Radcliffe and his calling card
character Igor okay buddy Victor Franks
I was not a good movie I just can't stop
referencing it okay we'll go with Harry
Potter because look they're both clearly
Heroes time and time again so let's see
who is the best once and for all I know
I'm gonna get killed for this opinion
either way so remember we're all doing
this in good fun we're celebrating both
franchises I say you were scared it is
rotobaggins who does Step Up boldly in a
big way earlier than does Harry because
Frodo volunteers himself as the ultimate
Jeweler offering to be the one to take
the ring to Mordor while the rest of the
council is bickering about who should do
it it may not have been his task to
undertake Gandalf is appreciative yet
apprehensive but he's the one that
enlisted and that scores Major hero
points in my book but let's also look at
the fact that Harry Potter isn't in jail
on multiple automobile theft charges
that's heroic because look at his
background he just lost his parents he's
got to live with a pretty hard on an
uncle and he still turned out to be a
good egg and he only stole one car right
the one that flew I'll take it he'll
also save you from trolls he'll take the
game-winning shot and quidditch the kid
can really do it all but just the fact
that he's a nice person after what he's
been through gets him on the scoreboard
early as well one of the most impressive
features about Harry is that he learns
from his heroic mistakes there's plenty
of times when he's up to the task of
saving the day like in his first bout
with Voldemort since he was a Wee's eye
goat and he's just not quite ready much
like the rookie quarterback throwing a
lot of interceptions he's learning how
to be great the hard way on purpose
Frodo never really wanted to be great he
just likes hanging out with his Pals
even the ones that don't always deserve
his affection like Gollum he tries to
get him some help and then there's the
real tried and true buddies like Sam and
the whole reason he had to save him from
drowning is because Frodo wanted to take
to the Seas simply to get out of the way
of our other beloved characters saving
them from harm that guy's a mensch but
it's hard to get more Menchie than Harry
Potter stepping up at the moment of
truth when he's willing to sacrifice
himself to destroy Voldemort once and
for all and this is with the assumed
knowledge that Hermione and Ron are
going to get together making him the
friend on the outside look dude I've
been the Third Wheel I am still in most
scenarios just keep believing actually
set off all these years I'll just sort
of go with it
Frodo Rises to the occasion as well only
really giving into the ring when it's a
first down away from meeting its demise
in the volcano
the ring is mine
all the riddle solving and selfless
decision-making came down to that one
moment and we got the job done all
without wearing shoes it's an Underdog
Story for Frodo a Tom Brady if you will
who went unnoticed until the sixth round
of the draft and was finally taken as a
backup quarterback Harry Potter he's got
the pedigree like a John Elway chosen by
birth to be great and living up to the
legend so who's better well in football
that debate mostly goes one way these
days but in art I gotta imagine the most
pressure is on being someone who's
always been referenced as the one that
kind of pressure has cracked many a
character before and it's all folks like
Anakin Skywalker break bad under the
spotlight of temptation but Harry stayed
true throughout and even after he did
die briefly taking a Voldemort he held
on to his fart until it was more
appropriate to do so in Swiss army man
Harry Potter gets the win of the Wild
Card round and thus Daniel Radcliffe
takes the match you make it almost too
easy as I reference throughout this
episode I know there's plenty of Lord of
the Rings and Harry Potter fans watching
this and you have your fervent opinions
and that's all fair and well so let us
hear them now you can hit me up anytime
on social media at Mark Ellis live check
in with our team at Rotten Tomatoes but
also there's a lot of other movies these
two artists have been in so check them
out maybe they're not all for you but
the ones that are really going to get
your goat speaking of goats well we had
Frodo we had Harry today so all that's
left to say is uh I guess we'll be
seeing you real shortly here on versus
I'm your host Mark Ellis and uh Gollum
this one's for you